[Música]
bienvenidos al espacio de medio ambiente
de france 24 yo soy maría clara calle y
es un gusto estar con ustedes y hoy
analizaremos que se logró en la cumbre
climática con 26 y también explicaremos
cuáles fueron las discusiones más
difíciles los líderes de casi 200 países
se reunieron durante 14 días en la
ciudad escocesa de glasgow para pactar
nuevos compromisos e intentar reducir el
calentamiento global el principal
resultado fue que se comprometieron a
reducir la energía basada en carbón
acordaron discutir la financiación para
pérdidas y daños y tendrán metas más
ambiciosas para la cob del próximo año
en egipto y para el 2030 prometieron
frenar la deforestación y disminuir los
gases de metano el mayor logro fue que
por primera vez en una cumbre climática
hubo acuerdos para limitar los
combustibles fósiles como el carbón que
es el que más contamina sin embargo la
redacción del acuerdo cambió a última
hora por la presión de india y china-
aurora valle explica que ocurrió y hace
un recuento de que es el llamado pacto
climático de glasgow
eres eres aire con una referencia sin
presidentes a los combustibles fósiles
un acuerdo climático de la cob 26
bautizado como pacto climático de
glasgow el lector se adoptó tras dos
semanas de complejas negociaciones que
tuvieron que prolongarse durante casi 24
horas por desacuerdos la principal
discordia en la recta final de la
redacción se refería a los términos de
la pretendida eliminación del carbón el
pacto final se refiere ahora a su
reducción gradual en lugar de una
eliminación apologize fue tuve dispersas
us and shoulders puedo decir a todos los
delegados que me disculpo por la forma
en que se desarrolló este proceso pero
creo que también es vital que protejamos
este plan de gestión es decir
y ya lideró ese cambio de última hora
alegando que los países en vías de
desarrollo aún necesitan utilizar
combustibles fósiles pero varios países
incluidos los pequeños estados insulares
se mostraron profundamente decepcionados
por la decisión el pacto climático de
glasgow también vuelve a comprometerse
con el objetivo de limitar el
calentamiento global a 1.5 grados
celsius el pacto también supuso un duro
golpe para las naciones más pobres que
buscan compensación por pérdidas y daños
causados por el calentamiento global
eeuu y la unión europea dos de los
mayores emisores del mundo se
resistieron a un plan de apoyo
financiero
hablemos entonces del acuerdo de carbón
la presión de última hora de india y
china- hizo que se cambiaran unas
palabras que modificaron por completo el
compromiso el primer borrador que se
conoció del 10 de noviembre hablaba de
una eliminación progresiva del carbón
pero la versión final del 13 de
noviembre reemplazo esto y hablo de
reducción esto favorece especialmente a
las dos naciones asiáticas que se
opusieron y es que solamente china e
india- han producido el 95 por ciento de
las nuevas capacidades de energía de
carbón en todo el mundo desde el 2011
por otro lado los países más vulnerables
a los impactos del cambio climático
rechazaron la reformulación del pacto
en nombre de las islas marshall quiero
dejar constancia de nuestra profunda
decepción por el cambio de palabras
entre eliminación o reducción de carbón
pedí que esto se refleja en el informe
de esta reunión este compromiso sobre el
carbón era un punto brillante del pacto
era una de las cosas que queríamos
lograr acá y llevarla con orgullo a casa
y duele profundamente ver como ese punto
brillante se oscurece aceptamos el
cambio con la mayor reticencia lo
hacemos públicamente y enfatizó
únicamente porque hay elementos críticos
del pacto que la gente de mi país
necesita como un salvavidas para su
futuro y china respondió a las críticas
diciéndoles a las naciones en desarrollo
que primero garanticen sus propias
fuentes de energía triunfar en un goya
muchos países en desarrollo aún no
tienen acceso universal a la
electricidad ni un suministro de energía
adecuado antes de exigirle a los países
que finalicen el uso del carbón primero
deben considerar la brecha de demanda de
energía en estos territorios para
garantizar su seguridad energética y
para entender mejor esto está conmigo
marina colorado nuestra enviada especial
a glasgow ya de regreso en bogotá y a
quienes ustedes conocen en este programa
marina bienvenida de nuevo y expliquen
los cuales la tensión entre reducir o
eliminar el carbono pues como bien le
mencionaba china e india son los dos
mayores exportadores de este material y
dos de los países los dos países más
poblados del mundo con una alta
población vulnerable que dependen del
carbón para calentar sus hogares para
poder cocinar según ellos según una
china e india- y varios otros países
ellos sienten que es injusto que se
tengan por objetivo este solo material
este solo este único combustible fósil
porque según ellos deberían también
mencionar otros combustibles fósiles más
utilizados en los países más
industrializados
por ejemplo el gas natural ellos dicen
que es injusto para china para india
para muchos otros países en vías de
desarrollo que se les esté pidiendo
ahora que dejen de usar el carbón cuando
los países ahora ya industrializados
tuvieron más de 100 años desde la
revolución industrial para quemar este
material y hacerse con unas economías
fuertes y sólidas gracias a la quema de
estos combustibles ellos lo que dicen es
que debería haber un uso justo del
presupuesto de carbono que existe en el
planeta que es decir cuánto podemos usar
o cuánto cada país puede usar del
carbono que tenemos disponible antes de
pasarnos de ese límite de
sobrecalentamiento de la tierra y la
otra gran tensión fue por dinero las
naciones insulares con el g77 que
incluye a china pidieron que se creará
un mecanismo separado para financiar la
restauración frente a las pérdidas y los
daños causados por el cambio climático
pero eeuu y la unión europea se
opusieron ellos temen que les pidan
indemnizaciones por ser unos de los que
históricamente más han contaminado el
resultado fue que en vez de ese
mecanismo pactaron el llamado día luego
de glasgow una conversación durante los
próximos dos años para debatir las
finanzas los menos desarrollados
rechazaron la decisión
estamos decepcionados de que el
mecanismo de glasgow para pérdidas y
daños no esté incluido en la decisión
final nuestra gente ya está
experimentando una avalancha creciente
de pérdidas y daños causados por el
cambio climático
escuchamos un reconocimiento
generalizado de esta injusticia pero
hubo un fracaso para abordarlo a este
descontento se suma la promesa que han
incumplido los países más ricos desde el
2009 prometieron que para el 2020 darían
100 mil millones de dólares cada año
para que las naciones en desarrollo se
adaptarán al cambio climático y
mitigarán los impactos pero al 2019
habían dado cerca de 70 mil millones de
dólares y la mayor parte de ellos en
préstamos con intereses altos
marín a explíquenos qué pasó en la cope
26 sobre financiación y por qué la
diferencia entre los países
desarrollados y los en vías de
desarrollo pues hubo algunas buenas
noticias y algunos avances en cuanto a
financiación porque se alcanzó un récord
de financiamiento para el fondo de
adaptación se alcanzaron los 356
millones de dólares que estarán
exclusivamente dedicados a la adaptación
y no serán compartidos con fondos para
la mitigación sin embargo dentro del
contexto de lo que se necesitaría que
son 70 mil millones para el 2030 pues
obviamente esta cifra siempre se queda
pequeña los países además se
comprometieron a aumentar en un bueno no
se comprometieron la cob el documento de
la cob le pide a los países que se
comprometan a doblar el dinero que ellos
dan para el 2025 con respecto al dinero
que se dio en 2019 para precisamente
fondos de adaptación pero ahí está la
falta de credibilidad como tú
mencionabas de que llevan prometiendo
esto desde el 2009 pero todavía no se ha
conseguido el tema más polémico de
financiación fue el tema de los daños y
las pérdidas ahí lo que los países en
vías de desarrollo están pidiendo es
dinero para los daños que están
sufriendo ahora no en el futuro no
dentro de 30 años de 50 de dos años
ahora los que han sufrido antes y los
que van a sufrir ahora y esto es al
lugar lo que los países industrializados
como bien mencionabas también no quieren
hacerse responsables porque ellos dicen
que debe hacerse de asumir su
responsabilidad
así abrirían las puertas a posibles
demandas legales a las que no quieren
enfrentarse entonces lo que no quieren
hacer es asumir esta responsabilidad y
entregar dinero para que los países en
vías de desarrollo puedan hacer frente a
estos gastos de daños y pérdidas fue el
tema con el que hubo más descontento en
general en la cob y del que todavía no
ha habido ninguna solución porque hay
una red de santiago que se han formado
pero hasta ahora es simplemente un
mecanismo de ayuda técnica para el que
no hay un financiamiento particular y
los países en vías de desarrollo están
pidiendo que esto sea algo más claro y
más conciso y en estas 26 pasó algo
inusual y es que desde el 2015 en el
acuerdo de parís los países se
establecieron que cada cinco años iban a
renovar sus metas para hacerlas más
ambiciosas eso fue lo que pasó ahorita
en esta cop sin embargo acordaron que
para el próximo año en la cob 27 en
egipto también renovarán sus metas
porque qué pasó pues porque todavía hay
varios países unas decenas de países
unos 40 que no han presentado estas n
veces con las conocidas de n veces que
son las contribuciones determinadas a
nivel nacional sus planes de reducción
de emisiones a futuro
con las que ahora mismo hay presentes y
existentes realmente estamos encaminados
a un aumento de temperaturas a finales
del siglo de 24 grados algo que se aleja
muchísimo es casi el doble del objetivo
del acuerdo de parís que es 1,5 grados
así que lo que tienen que hacer es lo
que quieren hacer es presionar estos
países precisamente los que no han
presentado ningún plan revisado a que lo
hagan el año que viene en egipto en la
cob 27 y a los que las han entregado que
las entreguen pero mejoradas revisadas
más ambiciosas porque además las que se
han presentado hasta el momento eran las
que abarcaban el periodo hasta el 2030
ahora falta también que presenten las
que van de aquí del 2031 perdón hasta el
2040 la siguiente década así que lo que
se busca es que cada año haya más
ambición y que haya más presión para que
los países realmente se comprometan a
bajar este nivel de emisiones y por
fuera del pacto del glasgow hubo otros
dos acuerdos sobre deforestación y gases
de metano cuéntenos en qué consisten y
qué tan efectivos pueden ser pues el
primero que menciona es el de
deforestación son más 30 países que se
comprometieron a revertir la
deforestación a frenar la y también la
degradación de los suelos es un paso
todo esto antes del 2030 es un paso
importante porque además hubo varios
países que se sumaron nuevos países que
se han sumado como por ejemplo rusia
brasil o china que no estaban en un
pacto muy similar que ya se había hecho
en 2014 en nueva york pero que no se ha
cumplido todo esto de todos estos pactos
tras estas promesas estos compromisos
realmente no sirven de nada si no hay un
mecanismo de monitoreo y de
transparencia que haga que los países
realmente cumplan con estas metas así
que bueno todo todo depende de que los
países realmente si lohan para esta meta
de deforestación serían 19 mil millones
de dólares de fondos públicos y privados
por otro lado y uno de los primeros
anuncios que hubo fue el de más de
ciento 105 países que se comprometieron
a bajar en un 30% sus emisiones de
metano al 2030 varios países clave en
esto no están incluidos como australia
china india y rusia aunque china luego
anunció que se unía en una alianza con
eeuu para el año que viene presentar un
plan de reducción de metano aunque no ha
dicho para cuando marine muchas gracias
por toda esta información y es un placer
tenerte de regreso ustedes recuerden que
pueden ver este y todos nuestros
programas en nuestro canal de youtube
nos vemos
[Música]